Dr. Reynard had lost everything.
His job, the respect of his peers, and if
everyone else was right, perhaps even his
mind.
It was eleven PM when he staggered to the
edge of Okanagan Lake, in British Columbia,
eyes and judgment clouded with booze.
This lake could have been what made his career
as a researcher for the SCP Foundation, but
now that bright future was slipping through
his fingers like the dry silt beneath his
feet.
He looked hatefully across the endless, dark
surface of the water and loudly cursed.
Stupid, empty place.
Just hours ago, he’d been stripped of his
ranks and released from his position at the
Foundation, for wasting the organization’s
time and resources on frivolous personal projects.
Frivolous, he thought.
What a terrible joke.
Just because the higher-ups refused to acknowledge
what was going on out here didn’t mean it
wasn’t there.
Dr. Reynard sighed and took another long swig
from his scotch bottle.
Moonlight shimmered off the water’s surface...Wait,
was that moonlight, or was something lurking
underneath the water?
To truly answer this question - if any answer
is possible at all - we need to go back to
the beginning, and ask ourselves a different
question: How does the SCP Foundation actually
find most of the anomalies it catalogs and
contains?
It’s a simple question with a multifaceted
answer, depending on the anomaly in question.
For the most part, the Foundation has a network
of field agents embedded in pretty much every
institution across the globe, including rival
groups of interest like the Global Occult
Coalition and the Serpent’s Hand.
If they so much as sniff the strange and unusual,
they alert the nearest site director and the
necessary personnel are dispatched to the
scene.
There’s also the Foundation web crawlers,
which are a form of specialized software,
constantly patrolling the web for anomalous
activity that the Foundation wants to know
about.
And one of the rarer, but still incredibly
important, methods of finding SCPs involve
looking into myths and local legends.
Sure, that may seem like a good way to waste
time and resources, but the crossover between
recorded SCPs and folklore is surprisingly
common.
Take SCP-1000, the formerly hyper-intelligent
apes that were nearly the dominant species
on earth until humans and a certain capricious
forest god pulled a dirty trick on them.
They’re better known to most civilians as
the legendary Bigfoot or Sasquatch, perhaps
the most famous cryptid of all time.
Or SCP-1337, the Hitchhiker, an anomalous
spectral entity that manifests in the cars
of those who don’t pick her up, and performs
horrific acts of violence against them.
She’s eerily similar to legends you can
find not only all over the US but the entire
world, of ghostly hitchhikers intruding into
the cars of unwary travelers and scaring them
half to death - or worse, if you’re unlucky.
Another case where myths and legends pointed
the SCP Foundation in exactly the right direction.
And of course, there’s SCP-136, the terrifying
Naked Doll.
This was an almost featureless children’s
doll found inside an abandoned house, but
prolonged time in its presence can make you
the victim of a warped apparition that’ll
drive you half-mad with fear.
It’s got such a detrimental psychological
effect on people that the Foundation has been
controversially using it as a torture method
during “enhanced interrogation” sessions
with captured members of rival groups of interest.
And how did they find it?
The Foundation keeps track of neighborhood
rumors about haunted houses with supposedly
supernatural inhabitants.
Clearly, when it looks like it might actually
get results, no myth or local legend is too
big or too small to warrant an investigation
from the SCP Foundation.
It was with this mindset that a younger, happier,
and less drunk Dr. B Reynard set off with
his team to Okanagan Lake, in search of what
locals had referred to as the legendary Ogopogo.
We’ve all heard of the Loch Ness Monster,
the lake monster from Scotland that’s been
turning heads for the better part of a century
- and may be related to two other similar
SCPs, namely SCP-3934 and SCP-5533 - but the
Ogopogo is Canada’s answer to good ol’
Nessie.
While the Loch Ness Monster resembles a plesiosaur,
the Ogopogo is much more serpentine, with
a long, coiling body covered in green scales.
Its long tail is said to be able to create
fierce storms along the surface of the water
with its vicious whips, killing scores of
unfortunate adventurers who dared stray too
close.
The name “Ogopogo” is also a palindrome,
meaning it reads the same forwards and backward,
and is believed to have originated in a novelty
song from the year 1924.
However, it’s likely that the actual beast
this somewhat goofy name was given to is a
much older, fiercer, entity.
And for the sake of his reputation as a researcher
as he took a plane to the Okanagan Valley,
Dr. Reynard very much hoped this was the case.
Of course, he’d explored the legends heavily,
so much so that he was sure there had to be
something to this whole thing.
To the two tribes native to the area, the
Secwépemc and Syilx
peoples, the lake-dwelling monster was known
as Naitaka, which has been loosely translated
into the “sacred creature of the water”,
the “water god”, and most menacingly of
all, the “water demon.”
The beast was often described in oral traditions
as being a malicious supernatural entity,
with great power and ill-intent towards those
trespassing on its territory.
Legend has it that anyone who crosses Okanagan
Lake, the supposed domain of the Ogopogo,
needs to make a sacrifice to the monster in
order to ensure safe passage.
Those who refused to give the sacrifice the
beast demanded would pay a heavy toll: Being
devoured or dragged down to a watery grave,
never to be seen again.
And this monster isn’t just some old folktale,
either.
Contemporary sightings have dated back to
1873, with both settlers and first nations
people alike spotting the sinister Ogopogo
in the intervening years.
Dr. Reynard had pored through the files on
hundreds of sightings - There were a number
of incidents in the 1980s, so much so that
environmentalist group Greenpeace moved to
have the creature classified as a protected
species.
Naturally, official sources decided against
the idea, claiming that none of the sightings
were of substance.
In 1992, a vast shape filmed under the murky
water in Okanagan Lake was suggested to be
the legendary beast.
However, the FBI stepped in to deny the validity
of this case, stating that the beast was much
more likely to be debris fallen off a local
tree, disappointing lovers of the strange
and unusual everywhere.
In 2011, nearly 20 years later, there was
more video footage of a sighting, showing
large, dark shapes moving underneath the surface
of the Okanagan Lake.
However, this claim was once again dismissed
by all outside parties, claiming the shape
of the beast underneath the water was more
likely to be a pair of logs.
Bummer.
2018 was an exciting year for the Ogopogo,
with three different sightings of the creature
being reported at different times throughout
the year.
Witnesses described the creature as being
a giant snake, around fifty feet long, which
is consistent with a lot of the historical
descriptions of the beast as well as being
over twice as long as the reticulated python,
the non-anomalous longest snake in the world.
So, naturally, authority figures once again
shot down the validity of any claims that
the creature was actually real and out there.
Dr. Reynard found it almost funny: They didn’t
even need to suppress knowledge of this creature.
If it really was out there, mainstream sources
seemed to be doing their job for them and
keeping the creature covered up.
He was determined, though, that he would be
the one to prove to his superiors that this
creature was indeed real, and lurking in Okanagan
Lake.
He organized a number of varied investigative
missions: From actively trawling the lake
itself, to conducting interviews with first-hand
witnesses as well as those who claimed to
see no merit in their evidence and testimony.
Dr. Reynard noticed a strange phenomenon:
The people who’d seen it first-hand were
as certain that it was real as the doubters
were that it was fake.
Even for typical skeptics, the non-believers
seemed shockingly resolute that there really
was nothing down there, and the alleged photos
and videos were 100% bogus.
Early diagnostic tests into the lake, directly
overseen by Dr. Reynard, seemed to point to
a creature clearly being down there.
He found the direct testimony both compelling
and consistent with what he and his team were
catching glimpses of, so why were people so
adamant that nothing was down there?
It was almost like the Ogopogo really was
as mystical as the First Nations legends said,
and it was casting a spell on all the non-believers.
That was when it hit Dr. Reynard like a perfect
bolt of lightning: They weren’t just looking
at a particularly large sea snake with unnatural
longevity here, they were looking at a sea
serpent with cognitohazardous powers.
It was a beast with a perfect defense mechanism
- Only those who saw it up close would actually
believe that the creature was real, anyone
who found out about it via secondary sources
would experience an extreme state of incredulity.
Nobody except those who saw it directly would
ever believe that it existed, and thus, even
the most intelligent prey would lower their
defenses around its domain.
An elegant and dangerous anomalous hunter.
Dr. Reynard had found himself a worthy opponent,
and one that would help him make his mark
at the Foundation.
He drew up the file and gave it the designation
SCP-1933, before sending it back to his supervisors.
They wrote back, saying they didn’t feel
as though there was enough of a basis in evidence
to deem this entry worthy of inclusion.
If Dr. Reynard wanted to have his so-called
Ogopogo dignified with entry into the SCP
Foundation Archives, he needed to back it
up properly.
This presented a problem to Dr. Reynard: How
could he provide documentation and evidence
for a creature that had the defining anomalous
power of making all of its own documentation
and evidence seem phony?
He was caught between a rock and a hard place,
with only one solution: Create the most undeniably
high-quality evidence of the creature that
the world had ever seen.
Not long after that, his superiors at the
SCP Foundation would receive a video file
from Dr. Reynard.
According to the notes on his report, he’d
set up a trap using an elk carcass to lure
the creature out of the water, and capture
HD video of it feeding.
When the senior researchers gathered around
to watch the video, they were astounded.
It was...An animatronic.
A cheap, rubber suit around a somewhat janky
robot, like something you’d see at a theme
park.
How much had Dr. Reynard spent on this absurd
farce?
Did he think this was funny?
Despite Dr. Reynard’s protests, he was reprimanded
severely for this waste of Foundation resources.
The object class on his 1933 file was switched
to “EXPLAINED” - meaning a rational, non-anomalous
explanation for the observed phenomena had
been found, discrediting it - and the 1933
slot was instead filled with a strange, fat
man dressed as Santa Claus, whose bodily fluids
are all Irish Cream.
The ultimate humiliation.
Dr. Reynard was left with nothing, and we
join him once again where we started, with
a drunken Dr. Reynard standing on the edge
of Okanagan Lake, staring hatefully into the
water as something seemed to move underneath.
If Dr. Reynard screamed that night, there
was nobody there to hear it.
His remains were dredged out of the lake the
next day.
His official cause of death was listed as
drowning after an unfortunate boating accident,
though the boat in question was never found.
Reports that his corpse was found “half-eaten”
have mostly been dismissed as rumors.
After all, there’s no such thing as the
Ogopogo.
Now go check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of
the HMS Wintersheimer” and “The Horror
of Body Stealing Rain - SCP-3300” for more
ominous aquatic anomalies!